yeah I I see what went wrong the last
time and I'm not going to let you down
please don't okay costumes are the cost
of Humes well no not it that's not it
these are the nominees for achievement
and costume design allied costume
designed by Joanna Johnston
fantastic beasts and where to find them
costume design by Colleen Atwood
Florence Foster Jenkins costume design
by Cancellara boy Jackie
costume design by modeling content
la-la-land costume design by Mary Jo
free okay the Oscar goes to Colleen
Atwood fantastic beasts and where to
find
this is the fourth Oscar and twelfth
nomination for Colleen Atwood who
previously Coco masters in this category
for Chicago Memoirs of a Geisha and
Alice in Wonderland
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
thank you I'm truly floored sting tell
me when tonight I didn't believe like
what
obviously I didn't prepare anything
thank you to warner brothers for their
tremendous really support supportive
team see Papazian my amazing director
lovely david yates it's just like a
special treat to work with him and my
amazing team and the rest of the people
who I've forgotten about tonight thank
you all very much my kids who are here
with me thanks so much
[Applause]